Son premier cours est « Révolutions intergalactiques et vous »
et America est si impatiente, elle est prête à montrer sa force,
à exhiber ses compétences d'ouverture de portails au poing
(Rires)
et je lui ai immédiatement ôté ce filet de sécurité.
J'ai limité ses pouvoirs, j'ai changé sa position
et bouleversé son monde parce que c'est ça l'université.
(Rires)
Surtout si vous êtes seul.
Mais je ne voulais pas qu'America soit trop longtemps seule
alors, durant un devoir ayant mal tourné,
elle atterrit sur le champ de bataille avec les X-Men.
(Rires)
Car, quand j'étais à l'université,
le révérend Kelly Brown Douglas était mon mentor
et je savais qu'America Chavez avait aussi besoin d'un mentor.
Qui de mieux placé que Tornade pour être la mentore d'America Chavez,
la première super-héroïne noire
et l'un des membres les plus puissants des X-Men ?
Personne.
(Rires)
Tornade enseigne à America comment apaiser son esprit
dans un portail galactique
et quand America apaise son esprit, elle ouvre les dimensions
et, dans ce silence,
elle peut écouter tout et tout le monde.
Personne ne lui a jamais offert le silence et la réflexion profonde
en tant que façon d'être forte.
Au début, elle rejette cela mais avec les encouragements de Tornade,
le déclic arrive,
America calme le monde qui l'entoure
et s'avance vers une profonde vulnérabilité.
Tornade et elle se font même un câlin,
je sais.
C'est parce que mes mentors m'ont assez aimée
pour m'encourager à m'explorer, moi et mes ancêtres,
et quand vous avez 19 ans, comment savoir ce que cela signifie ?
Je n'ai pas appris l'histoire des miens à l'université.
J'ai appris l'histoire des miens assise sur les genoux de ma grand-mère
quand elle a sorti l'album photo
et qu'elle a nommé tous ceux qui étaient là et ceux restés sur l'île.
Évidemment, une grand-mère devait atterrir d'urgence dans la vie d'America Chavez
et pas n'importe quelle grand-mère -- une grand-mère grande, forte, une battante
qui l'aimait assez pour l'amener dans le plan ancestral,
où America Chavez pourrait voir l'histoire des siens
se dérouler dans les cieux.
America voit la planète Fuertona,
la planète natale de sa grand-mère,
la voit être envahie
et voit sa grand-mère et sa mère fuir.
Elle voit également la joie qu'elles éprouvent
quand leur nouvelle patrie les accepte ouvertement
et s'occupe très bien d'elles.
Elle voit l'immense douleur à laquelle répond une compassion plus grande encore
et cela existe aux côtés de l'immense force de sa famille.
Partout où je le pouvais,
je lui ai écrit des mots doux
pour elle et pour tous les autres enfants homosexuels de couleur
essayant d'être formidables.
Quand vous vous perdez,
plongez dans votre ascendance car vous y trouverez les morceaux.
Cela vous rappellera également que la tendresse n'est pas l'autorisation
d'esquiver, de se cacher, de se taire, de battre en retraire.
La tendresse vous pousse aussi
à vous tenir pour responsable.
Comme quand America atterrit durant la seconde guerre mondiale,
se retrouve face-à-face avec Hitler
et l'assomme...
(Rires)
comme l'a fait Captain America en 1941.
Qui aurait cru que nous aurions besoin
qu'America Chavez frappe des Nazis en 2018.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et même cela, cet acte justifié la dévaste un peu
alors je me suis assurée qu'elle contacte sa meilleure amie,
qu'elles parlent sentiments, partent faire une virée en voiture
et chantent à tue-tête « Just a Girl » de No Doubt.
(Rires)
Quand Midas, une sinistre entreprise,
prend le contrôle de Sotomayor,
menace d'interdire les portails et va presque jusqu'à tuer America...
ses ancêtres entrent en contact avec elle
car elles savent qu'elle a besoin de guérir.
Et c'est cet élan d'attention, cette guérison qui lui donne la force
de vaincre Midas et de redevenir elle-même.
Car ce mythe
selon lequel il faut agir seul et être dur à cuire
ne nous rend pas service.
America Chavez est une super-héroïne entière
et a quand même eu besoin d'une équipe pour la soutenir
et l'aider à se trouver.
Elle a eu besoin de cette douceur,
le genre de douceur prenant racine dans la compassion
et restant engagée pour la justice et la libération.
Car c'est dans cet espace où la douceur et la vulnérabilité rencontrent la force
que l'on transcende son soi ordinaire,
que l'on devient quelque chose de plus grand, de majestueux,
peut-être même de super.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)